you also just released a greatest hits
collection called diamonds and redstones
I love the title is it true that yours
on Two Doors Down was about fried clams
it was but see I need the story I'm like
you no I've always had a problem with my
weight too up and down I love to eat
I've been up and I've been exercising
the world and a long time ago yeah it
was getting me depressed I didn't like
it so I was you know you try everything
to you know to lose weight and I had got
on some kind of crazy old diet like a
liquid protein you just drink an ounce
of something that's ground up horse
Hooves or something
I don't know her monkey pee or something
I don't know but it was just yeah but
you're supposed to drink it like three
times a day and it was so ungodly you
just have to close the back of your
throat off so you don't smell you know
how it goes but no thanks we we used to
stay at the Howard Johnson's Motor Lodge
the band when we travel back in the
early days and they had a restaurant
there and they had these fried clams
that we couldn't wait to stop to go to
Howard Johnson's even if we weren't
staying over we'd stop to eat the fried
clams yeah but we were staying over and
I was on that stupid liquid protein diet
and the band was down in the kitchen and
I was in the in a hallway in my room and
I could hear them all laughing and
talking that's what I'm saying you could
start saying I was just saying uh like
uh two doors down two doors down there
laughing and drinking and having a party
but two doors down they're not aware
that I'm round but here I am just crying
my heart out feeling sorry
I'm having a party just two doors down I
was just sitting there feeling sorry for
myself because I was eating fried clams
I love I love that song it's about now
and it was two doors down I was staying
two of those down from the restroom
that's why seriously
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]